Jesus Christ I am the goddess of
destruction um yeah
so nothing much happened to this episode
holy yeah that was nice very
disappointed yeah I know we were gonna
get a great reveal and maybe some more
answers or something most Dan's brother
really then they went all lost on us and
didn't say yeah no this was um pretty
amazing uh some of the biggest questions
were answered in this one only to raise
even more it's a good industry does that
the races for questions but yes this is
not what he seems I actually because we
it just came out we just saw I don't
have the codes decoded whenever I'll try
to get it next time
uh but yeah this episode's fan is
arrested for stealing wasn't like
nuclear waste or something like that
yeah and he went out Doc Brown you know
made some deals with some Libyans from
Plutonian or something and healing
government waste taken away and uh Mabel
and dipper trying to figure out if
they're the con artist uncle is a really
bad con artist uncle in terms of like
he's more evil than they thought and he
has all these different identities Stan
Pines may not even be his name cuz they
find an article saying Stan Pines is
dead which means then Stan Pines is
probably his brother then possibly oz of
his brother yet I wouldn't be like maybe
we should fake your own death kind of
thing alright so I don't know what to
believe before
so mostly episode is this supposed to
doomsday machine
getting started up they believe it's a
doomsday machine it kind of might be
because all the evidence is saying this
could destroy the universe or whatever
universe still seems to be there Jim
brought Runkle not grunkle Stan back
yeah six fingers um and so he says but
it's important you got to go and let
this happen and it all comes down to a
dipper doesn't trust a stand but maple
still kind of does is the big point of
who does she believe and she decides to
not push the button and let the machine
go off and the universe is still there
but uh the author of the books comes in
it
the six figured percent is grunkle
Stan's brother yeah figured a 6-figure
figured person dude some sort of
homunculus six heads and which would be
even more awesome but still this was
pretty cool and like twelve arms and so
um yeah the one thing we were trying to
figure out like said we just saw this I
was like look up see if it's like the
last episode of the season or whatever
we didn't see anything that said that
was so I think he's having kind of
pissed because when you bring one
episode back and then another like weeks
later yeah it'd be ten episodes as
opposed to the twenty of the last one um
so probably not so I'm really looking
forward to more answers and such uh so
yeah so I mean some you know as so many
conspiracy theories are now sort of
brought to you know bit of a conclusion
part of it I mean we know it was for a
sibling you know it's definitely defined
a lost loved one yes just waiting there
whatever brother yeah was also the
Arthur had six fingers and is his
brother of the one thing going through
my head is that they were very they're
very particular about when the machine
was going and dippers hair was flying up
they were very specific to show the
Little Dipper mark on his head I'm worth
that's gonna come into play later uh
because I don't know because look at
their hair - I know realized dippers
hair and Stan's hair and even the
brothers hair they're very similar - so
because they're all series than men on a
sweater I've been on sweater watch or
swatch uh her sweater Mabel's sweater
was a key the key which she brought he
to open the door the key to trust um but
he wasn't trust she's just not pressing
a button well but because she trusted
stamp okay anyway um but yeah so I just
raises a lot of questions the last thing
we see we see two little kids two little
boys uh pretty obvious least and his
brother just on swings and you know
that's a hey I just realized at the
beginning she said she was the goddess
of destruction and depending on where
they go with this her actions are not
pressing the button maybe she is well no
but it's if she did if she did press the
funding would just stop but if
the brother won't come through so but
they thought maybe shall we have no idea
my my guess is that an unholy terror
will be unleashed because of this ah
like so that's the trade-off he gets his
brother back but something by not
pressing the button and shutting it down
is unleashed like you know maybe weird
triangle guy yeah and it may be like he
was going into whatever this dimension
or whatever to fight off or he got
trapped in there all you said maybe he
was the one in the car uh but if he
wrote the book and he wrote in there for
the love of God don't shut it down then
well maybe that's like how he got sent
through and then Stan was trying to
bring it back I mean it he got selected
or he saw other people get sucked
through or something um so yeah just
again some tree game I was gonna be
really pissed off if they've like they
pushed the button and the Stan's like
you know don't you know what you mister
he's like I was really praying they
weren't gonna go that route and just
keep the district going longer but I
really like they like really thrid some
you know a lot neater answers here not
all the rooms for way more mystery yeah
that's what that's what's so great about
it um definitely has kind of a lost vibe
with if you don't press this button or
the countdown to the end of the world
the bunker you know and yeah it's more
entertaining them yes that I can
actually follow it now there's a
definitely a lot of influence from that
but also I was saying I like that this
episode of gravity falls actually deals
with gravity and falling yeah you don't
really see anything happy uh on top of
the the story being you know a lot of
these big reveals uh the company was
still pretty good I like guy honestly I
thought this was one of the funniest
episodes he liked funny is evidence that
I will say it got less that the second
half wasn't as funny it wasn't meant to
be the first half were they seamlessly I
mean seamlessly run through all of this
exposition and still make it hilarious
you know right from the beginning with
the fireworks and the the cop callers
yeah and yeah the lawsuit bakery and um
every single line was funny it was
tightly written like I couldn't keep
track of all the funny lines like there
were just so many in a row and Wendy
coming in to work on is good go to work
today and the cop
I love that I love this watching coming
up to the pig it's just a cup we have a
pig sous-sous at the drive-in you know
oh my god it's just some sort of
possession thing I'm on the
walkie-talkie
oh yeah like it took me a minute to it's
just like how would he be talking to oh
okay yeah Dallas's dumbest Seuss yes yes
you work uh so yeah I I don't know I
thought it was really tightly written
yeah it got more serious in the second
half but the first half is some of the
funniest writing mmm you know I liked
the episode with the Pacifica and stuff
but in stranger ways that one was almost
a little more serious like as much as
they're revealing in this I thought this
was more serious in the second half but
like the first step is all about comedic
writing I give this line after line and
funny scene after funny scene in the
simple slapstick like slapping grunkle
Stan's head on to the car hood for no
particular reason because um the cop
stealing this time I'm actually innocent
yeah this time I'm actually this is the
cop stealing the icy-pop you know it I
like oh I just really fascinates me that
you could write a show that has serious
moments like this and yet still make it
this funny well I like to stop laughing
bonus 15 minutes all the excuses we're
making in our heads like well that's not
him in the suit or II you know and then
you hear like you know you know bailed
oh I knew that was in oh I knew that was
him in this you know no but it's like
they keep clapping it's like well equal
mercy every excuse of transit well come
on he's got to be good and so he has all
these identities we'll come on
he's our grunkle Stan its Stan Pines
dead in sand so it's even though I think
we know it's like okay the way their
animated name he's a main character he's
gonna be on to something good that's
meaningful and and smart and stuff you
know but uh but at the same time for the
characters to be seeing all this stuff
it's like yeah that's that's a lot of
damning evidence II you know and they
already know like he's kind of a
consummate it's like yes is really like
they haven't you know he didn't tell
them I'm not saying it's not serious
I'm saying that in its seriousness there
was actually a
lot more comedy going on here than I
thought there was in the previous
episode even like that big scene were
like that one was more yeah you learn
things about Pacifica like it wasn't his
epic serious as this with the big
reveals and all these things but it it
actually was way more funny so that's
what I mean by less well even the scene
where you know she's decide with her not
to push the bus she you know what she
has a lie you know I don't even know if
you're really my grunkle I mean it's
like that's just it's really dramatic
that's about shooting what yeah Jennifer
mission to protect these kids I mean
just a little joke in there that I think
adds a lot you know just s-series and
heavy as it is you know it can kind of
break it up a little bit and this will
be interesting because once again as it
should be it always comes down the Mable
yes Jackie now did she do myself
question but well even even she did when
in this case how we know if you can
blame her I mean is like cuz you see the
brother comes back and stuff like that
so it's a she did push the fun I'd be
really pissed you know the audience
would be really pissed so it's like why
cuz dipper is dipper is the head the the
brain which has its uses and functions
but you know occasionally you need your
gut instinct and she's all about like
this gut instinct you know ya know and
they both you know she can she can be
you know it's the brains and the emotion
and you need both you know dipper can
overthink too too much and lose track of
what's really important you know where
she can like you said trust her cup but
she can also get distracted by anything
you know whatever boy dance and all that
crap um so that they both play a part
which I think really works out well uh
enemies
does that make Stan like the Venkman
like he's the mouth this is the scared
the scammer the yeah no he's just lemme
Mabel is Raven uh and Egon and like
dipper would be Egon and then soos would
have to be Winston sadly but I mean he
is the blue-collar worker there or you
could L and then one day would be Janine
there yeah
so we need a gravity falls Ghostbusters
movie make this happen
yes were they're all naval engine empty
amazing yeah say I would totally why'd
you only watch the ik said they were
changing this Ghostbusters movie now
they were all gonna be Mabel it was
gonna be gravity falls I'd I'd be fine
with this I'd be okay with this only
saying Hollywood
so um ya know uh good stuff I can't
think of anything really wrong with it I
mean I this is one of those words so you
gotta wait until the end to see that all
adds up or whatever but it's like I'm
intrigued I'm really excited to see
where it's gonna go I hope this isn't
the season finale I don't think it is um
but I think we're still in the mode of
like let's see what happens since they
just did the big reveal yeah cuz so much
of it but again uh time I skip the class
again unlike lost which over ten don't
get me wrong like decent characters and
you know a decent writing and stuff uh
everything was riding on the mystery
we're with gravity falls let's say you
never find out what happened just to let
it very funny it was so funny and
there's still so many jokes in so many
characters I'm like this was totally
worth it I will say this though Benjamin
Linus as a character told me belongs on
gravity falls
his out-of-context lines would have been
perfect in the show you mean
time-traveling bunnies yes John yes
hi-ho I have a question I'm a Pisces I
could totally see him on gravity falls
as a character uh
so yeah we'll just see where it's going
uh exciting man and you know
it is getting real going down uh excited
ah didn't have the same heart got it
from from the belly just abdominal
breathing Elin you know what you work on
it it's good it's good ah